some people did you know do you know
what twitches twitch the app yeah
they're like the streaming thing yeah
yeah so you don't play games inside it
wasn't a there's a there's a like a sub
sector of twitch I can't remember what
it's called where they make noises with
their mouths and people who get turned
on us if they like it they get turned on
yeah
like they'll be like one ping white girl
or something or like an asian girl it's
never a black girl and they'll sit
literally this close to the mic and then
just go so it's like you know when
people lips your ear and you get this
tingle tingle I think that's what it
does to people
it's a revolt on twitch yeah people will
just they'll donate money for it they
love it I find that so weird yeah people
are fishes from sir a man have fetishes
what isn't the sole purpose of twitch
for games and stuff there's sub-sector
sayin that's weird bro probably we could
do this on Twitch if you wanted to if we
had like if I had say cuz it's I've
looked into it before like for my lap
obviously I use a laptop in it but to
stream you need a process of much better
than app talks so you want to use like a
PC if we used if we connected the camera
to a PC we could just live stream on
Twitch and just do this well obviously
you but you'd need to talk for hours and
hours and hours be pointless but if it's
time to think about in the future
yeah if I'm des weird sectors every time
this like something that's made for
something so twitch was made for gaming
people will figure out to use it for
sign house and it'll always turn into
something sexual always only fans felt I
need startin only fans and so what were
you gonna sell I don't know yeah what
body part you're gonna self up you know
what
I would like to say my dick but getting
imagine having to get your dick hard all
the time to take pictures and you need
angles for dick dicks aren't like tits
tits you can work from any angle as long
as the Lighting's right is fine ya dick
sperm not like I've ever sent a dick pic
I think I've sent like one dick pic on
my life from my request and I was
sweating I was sweating I was like um
thinking right how do I do this
shall I do it let the game and just like
get semi-hard and just do it in the
boxes so they can just see down like oh
do I just stop playing games and just
get it out haha and do they want did
they do they want me to get hard because
then they're thinking why I didn't want
to see the potential yeah oh dude dude
they want to see what they're gonna be
[ __ ] with at the same time they don't
want to see it soft
yeah no no and then so I'm like right so
we're going for like a semi situation
and then get into that perfect semi that
you're comfortable with yeah it's like
it's hard to its mighty simple BAM it
took me like 45 minutes to get its best
the best semi is once you bust a nut and
when it's about to go down that's the
best thing brav if you bust and then
quickly pull out you've got the perfect
day it's hard but soft that is a hard
and soft and you just like that's a dick
if I'll take this this is what that's
what dick this is what that's exactly
what she wants to of a dick pic that's
exactly what she wants at the same time
when I was watching uh what was I
watching
it was euphoria okay I'm not seeing that
yeah I was what I'd never finished it it
was really good I don't know I never
finished it they were talking about dick
pics and bearman obviously use like
bottles and cans and [ __ ] for
perspective mhm so you can see actually
how big it is
mm-hmm if that made me laugh because
I've never done that but I do
specifically remember when I did the
dick pic remember thinking like on
camera she can't tell how big this is
there's no reference points
but I never thought let me get a bottle
so she knows how big is I thought maybe
if I just lump it in my hand she'll be
able to tell from my hand it didn't work
from there was no reference point I
don't know if I don't never think I
slept with this girl so no I did I did I
did I did I had been sleeping with her
so it wasn't that much of a stress I do
remember that it did come to my head be
a dick pics are big they're hard man
deep unattended they're [ __ ] it's
just
oh girl can always send a sexy nude or
like a sexy bikini pic or whatever cuz
this is so easy for them that's why only
phones with em just pops but for a guy
if you ain't got a decent enough body
cuz what more can you take apart from a
dick pic there's nothing else that
entices a woman let's not give a [ __ ]
what's the chessmen agency every day
like what's the [ __ ] point there was
no point reven you can't guys can't get
sexy with it yeah there's not going to
do with it there's nothing sexy about a
dick pic is grotesque this light is
grotesque I don't know why I don't know
how a woman can look at a dick and think
YUM I'm gay yummy yummy I don't know how
they do it I've asked so many times like
is it you like about a dick yeah it's
just a lump of me
it's just nothing is nothing it's
literally nothing it's true there's no
enticement I don't know what they see I
think they get gassed about how they've
the potential of no way they feel like
yeah cuz they can look here if they've
if they've been around if they know
their way around a dick no look at
anything that's gonna do business yeah
that's gonna do business gonna hurt me
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] hurt me and
I'm here for it that reminds me of the
time years ago when I think up to
recently aired like the other day about
that sex set up the sex set up sitting
when you said you was jealous with me
and our friend and I am basically for
context myself and another friend my
friend at the table what our friend at
the time gosh we're talking in seven
years ago maybe
maybe for longer um was talking to a
girl she wanted to visit him she went to
get a hotel she randomly decided like
how can I bring a friend do you have any
single friends no offense you man went
up there was often no no no no we went
to Birmingham we didn't go up there okay
I mean it was out bins
yeah that's why said she wants get hotel
okay okay so yes she was like I want to
come down bring my friend go out for
some drinks you bring a friend we'll go
out come back to the hotel I was like
yes bring me through so we went there
ended up sleeping with this girl that
don't know didn't know didn't even talk
to her pretty much the whole time as I
was a bit weird but yeah that exact
thing was that we were having sex going
for it going for it going for it and
then out of nowhere she's like I'm gonna
be sore in the morning biggest turnoff
ever me being shy just carried on
plowing through I wanted to be like why
do you say that why what's wrong with
you how many guys have you [ __ ] to
feel comfortable to just monotone in not
even like out of breath yeah breath
singer she leave the park
I'm so sorry the morning just like I'm
gonna be sorry in the morning like
nothing wasn't like nothing's happening
sai-yuk oh my days
yeah she's she she'd been through some
dick definitely just funny oh my god
speaking of dick sighs hmm
this is like semi linked to something
else you want to know the one the
weirdest I feel like the last few
episodes a little bit talk about my
childhood I feel that my childhood is
actually coming out yeah I'm having
flashbacks about it and I'm like it
don't make sense you're about to get
what you mean the weirdest gayest well
it wasn't gay because we clearly didn't
know what gay was yeah so this is it
sounds thing is I want to say it sounds
worse than it is but it's not so
basically
hey this is so embarrassing firm oh why
did I bring up I'm started by the ring
up never mind anyway let's go for it
let's go for it um this was just bros
doing bro [ __ ] well we thought we were
Bros to him bro [ __ ] and we definitely
weren't we were just asexual kids
thinking we doing bro [ __ ] actually
doing gay [ __ ] so basically what
happened was yet this haven't I was a
kid I wasn't like EF no it must have
been like year six so he must've been at
10 or 11 I'm killing with my boy of
listen I did in Luton I was chilling
with my boy Christian and he used to
live of his granddad and he saw do you
want it after school is out I don't want
to come mine for a bit and chill I'm
like cool man
no this was year 7 I was like 11 or 12 I
remember because we just went to high
school right this what happened so we've
just got to high school I remember and
we used to hang out with his ear 10th or
11th and they just always chuck it to us
right and they were like ah you guys and
this is when like you were a kid and
your life through your teeth about
anything that doesn't even make sense
yeah yeah so there were like ah I bet
you're still a virgin
of course I'm at 7-7 course I'm a virgin
brother that's not why I said though I
was a smart off the thing did I didn't
have enough for sighs I'm like I'm being
[ __ ] I didn't even know a [ __ ]
wars come how am i I've been [ __ ] and
they're like shut up shut up shut up I
have a bit you having us out banking yet
and I'm like hey Rob this time my dick
didn't even work and then I'm like yeah
yeah wank
I don't even need to run cuz I'm just
[ __ ] I don't even need to work the
things I was saying didn't even make
sense
and then these tank guys when I'm an RA
wherever every Josh I chose sure so
these aren't I didn't even know what
wanking meant so I didn't know when you
like have a wank
it's I didn't know what it was for
like I didn't know I just knew what it
meant yeah I knew like how to do it but
I didn't know why you do it or like I
didn't know it's supposed to feel nice
and I didn't know anything I didn't even
know you were supposed to but I didn't
even know bus him was like I had no idea
about sex yeah and then some children
one boy Christian he was there during
this little conversation he was there
because they used to do it to us all the
time so we go to his granddad's house
with Chilean he's like yeah my
granddad's out we'll just chill at mine
for a bit we used each other all the
time so I'm alright cool man so we're
just chillin chillin chillin and then
he's like he's like but chillin watching
TV and he's like bro do you wanna watch
huh my mind's like no no I thought there
was porn involved there actually wasn't
even porn involved this is how you know
we knew nothing about sex okay we're
just chillin and my mind's like bro do
you want to have a wank and that was
like huh these times I didn't relate
having a link to sex yeah I didn't even
know so now I'm like huh have a way he's
like yeah yeah yeah
obviously we're chilling you wanna have
a wank he clear didn't know what it
meant
yeah and I'm like yeah I did feel uneasy
about it then yes okay we can we can
have a wank mmm and he's that awesome
so my mind pulls down his drawers gets
his twelve eleven year old dick out and
starts bash in fact just rigorously
bashing and my man like he weren't even
aroused or nothin fact he's just
violently badass dude he's soft piece
yeah yeah just bashing his soft white
talk and I'm like boom and I remember
sitting remember exactly sitting there
feeling so painfully uncomfortable yeah
but these sounds I'm still not relating
it to sex yeah and I'm like alright and
he's like well go on then come on then
like we're having a wank Bert like why
are you have it
do you whiny one kid and then I'm like
all right oh my days
Solis am somewhat so I didn't like pull
my piece out and I just like under the
cuff under the like yeah and I'm just
said up I didn't even know if I was
holding if I'm all set up and I'm like
this is weird
and then my man looks over to me and
psych Wow yo takes massive and then I
was like gay food but like pull my [ __ ]
up and was like gay and it's like a
lightning ball hit me and everything I
needed to know about sex hit me in that
one moment I was like this is gay I'm
out thanks for the rank burger I'm gone
[Laughter]
bro it was what is that what is that I
think back it anything what happened
there and I don't know I don't I I don't
think that's an isolated incident I
think young men are about to his firm
they don't know what I don't these times
of parents are saying we shouldn't be
teaching sex education like the primary
school you should fam you should because
me and Christian didn't know what we
were doing we in Christian didn't know
what we were doing and if his granddad
walked in he would have been shocked
I don't know fam oh I do all I know is
if granddad would sin he would have been
like what the [ __ ] is going on
nah fam nah such a weird story that's
hilarious bro
that's I hurt my chest as I say that's
the gays things ever happened to me yeah
it's not gay whatsoever it's nothing
there's nothing sexual about whatsoever
but from like an adult perspective now
okay it's like Jesus that was gay Jesus
that is gay to gents just in there
bashing out together that a gay [ __ ]
whoa okay
brah I remember screaming to the top of
my lungs
okay I'm going okay [ __ ] I'm out
Jesus nah that's that is gay is that
funny
[ __ ] that's funny James he reminded me
because I was thinking about what he
said about soft thick and just reminded
me of that it was such a weird oh my
gosh how hoods don't make sense it
doesn't I remember the first time I
tried to run away from home I've ever
thought thorry would you mean the first
time
no you I didn't mean in reference like
that all right well now you didn't tell
him I was in year buzz in primary school
I don't know what you're I was in bars
definite primary school so I was living
in Crystal Palace was it running away
from home or did I just go somewhere I
think you know I didn't run away from
home I went somewhere without telling my
parents oh yeah
so I think I had finished school went
home and I left home to go back to
school for like an after-school Club or
something like that
mm-hmm come knowing full well I'm not
talking my parents and Noah for what I
should have told my parents left dips
went to school I common way it was it
could have been skipping it gave me a
[ __ ] food it could mean something a
caramel one yeah yeah yeah I had left
come back home now rents were going
skits like obviously I'm a kid like I'm
four I miss cop obviously they trust me
to go to men for a school by myself
because I live close that where a [ __ ]
have you been
where the [ __ ] have you have been
terrified
James was beaten beaten they beat the
[ __ ] on me I say day my dad did mmm my
dad no it wasn't a double-team take my
dad just not to me the [ __ ] out your dad
abused to him it was just normal it's
normal for Nigerians mom yeah normal we
got bangs bangs women kids [ __ ] me I go
at Westat my sister Oh obviously because
just go and she yeah she never got
beaten up but she got armor one time I
should got what
brav perhaps you've got stories mum
my childhood was marked many times I
told you I've got a scar on my stomach
inna yeah I said he's on his podcast
yeah but um I finished the story you ran
away
yeah run away don't even know why I ran
away walk back home like la-dee-da like
yeah yeah yeah cool cool cool go ahead
where the [ __ ] have you been kind of
thing Carmen why I said cuz a caramel
was doing anyway and I went to I went to
do something in school so I asked and I
made a sense of it I'll do it
x y&z x y&z like what ah quickest
quickest slap wait was that thing ever
that you [ __ ] it ever go anywhere
telling us ever again
um it was crazy that happened to me one
time you know when it's funny because we
were just we were just talking about not
talking about but watching it on that
modem Gilligan ting mmm my dad used to
come and pick me up on a Saturday
morning in it yeah nice to be Jasper day
I don't know why I was so excited for
dad to come and pick us up
but I used to love it so I used to
literally sit on our doorstep waiting
for that to see dad's car coming down
the road so I'm waiting waiting waiting
one day one Saturday I'm waiting waiting
waiting I remember the summer I'm
sitting on Dorset my mom can say on the
door stay away for that she's like yeah
going I'm not cool that's taking long -
taking long so I'm like right I'm gonna
go to the end of the road and see if
he's coming yeah all right
went to the end of the road stayed there
for like 30 seconds max 30 seconds max
came straight back walked through the
door my mum clearly had thought that I'd
been taken or run away or something
because all she saw she's come to the
door the door swinging open and I'm not
on the doorstep and I must have been
young like six or seven hmm and I walked
in like said la-dee-da I didn't even see
the smoke coming from it
I got a smack on my Blind Side just bang
and I remember I clapped into the wall I
know that what's going on
did she just went [ __ ] nuts right
where the [ __ ] were you from
crazy anything why do parents get
violently angry when they're worried
when they're worried their first
instincts to beat the [ __ ] out you it
doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make any sense she came after
me fam went nuts and then my dad came in
and was I was ugly he finally got there
and then she told him to beat me almost
like this little [ __ ] like tried to
run away all like he went missing I
couldn't find him these times I was gone
for literally 30 seconds she beat the
living she beat her living Christ I
remember I was at my pad I remember I
always think in my head like [ __ ] mom
used to love beating us but that's not
like something that I just say all the
time to anyone and then I remember my
dad I say I remember this last week when
we went to my dad's for Christmas we all
sitting around the table and just
talking like catching up about old [ __ ]
and stuff like that and then we were
talking like me my brother being
naughtiest kids and stuff and he was
like boy
if I wasn't around I think your mom
would have killed you both she's like
any excuse to smack you up she was like
she went to take the skin off your legs
she is funny because I'd remember mum
used to smack us for joke I remember one
time I had a bunk bed and I was on the
top bunk
and I remember one time I don't feel
like she want to rip the skin off my
legs she was like I was half asleep
and I was trying to sleep and I was just
snooze on those dogs in fact yeah and
she kissed me on my cheek and I didn't
know what it was and I was like ah and
then I must have tapped her on her head
I don't know she thought it was an
attack fam in the middle of the night
she I remember this hammer and uh she
grabbed it and pinned his hand down and
my face was clean open and she just
[ __ ] went for her face see we're nuts
she said are you ever [ __ ] hit me uh
nope
oh oh oh my baby was out to get you
I'm six I'm [ __ ] six
oh my god my mom was a [ __ ]
she was such a [ __ ] she's the beat us
all the time on my chest her to see us
all the time and I remember the day I
remember the day telling her Alex don't
hurt any moon I remember she was so
angry
mmm so angry and I could tell her pride
wanted to ring my dad and say like these
kids are talking [ __ ] yeah they're
saying my smacks don't hurt me I come
true and show him what hurts kind of
thing she wanted to do that in it but
her pride was thinking now my smutch her
and then she was smacking me family and
I was there firm in him and I was
laughing I was laughing all right I hurt
when yes she wind up she didn't draw for
a weapon but she just went crazy and
dragged me to the floor and just going
[ __ ] crazy and I'm there like I this
don't hurt and it does hurt and my eyes
are tearing up tearing up rough and it
was starting to [ __ ] her and I'm
tearing up her and she's got like an e
on my back and she's going [ __ ] like
her hat must have been red raw red raw
as she's [ __ ] going for it and I'm
like dad I felt like couldn't suck in
say I felt I could to get a gay wit fam
she went crazy
prides that bad thing is her pride
versus my approach you always used to
say they say I said when I was a kid
that me and her two were like but we've
our pride and I'm stubborn us not shut
up I'm nothing like you
but that day proved that we were the
same I wasn't given in as she went given
in from she was gonna smack me until I
said it her and I wasn't gonna firm it
until she stopped Jesus that's not
that's not pairing and you say we go
peace she said you said she put a knee
on your back from a and down when she
slapped my head hand down my face I knew
my race was about to get it as soon as
my hand hit the pillow I knew my face
was about to get it it was long that's
ever so funny fun
- funny I've never been pinned down to
get people that's Irish women firm
they'll comfy I've never ever been
pinned down to get beat that's crazy bro
but these sounds like you've got a scar
I know I've got permanent scar but that
doesn't mean and you'll stomach awful
place yeah I can understand if it was
like on the back of your leg or your
arses on your stomach yeah if I was just
knock what did he hit you with what like
a bamboo stick it never broke Jesus
Christ healed this [ __ ] out my skin it's
never gonna go it's never ever gonna go
is it mad yeah crazy going but then
again like it's mad that my mom used to
go nuts just cause just because but
because she used to go not so often mmm
I didn't give a [ __ ] it didn't mean
anything anymore
so these smacks and they shout and then
stuff like that dipped me [ __ ] yeah just
like that's just Wednesday but my dad I
think I've heard my dad shout like three
times in my entire life yeah and when he
used to shout found my bones used to
crumble
really my dad shout like I don't know
what it was but my dad's never angry
yeah so when it shut like he he'd always
shout like out of nowhere he so be
monotone he's getting pissed off so it's
not like it's not like you can see him
rumbling nothing up yeah it's just like
say for example me my brother fighting
and he's like stop fighting guys stop
fighting behave yourself stop fired
we're not listening stop firing I said
stop fight firm when he shouted we froze
we froze and then he come this is honey
he come if he was gonna beat us ya head
car he'd come and grab like the back of
like the scruff of your neck and try and
turn you so your backs facing him and
you'll try and turn against him in it
and you're trying to turn against it and
he's dragging you and he's got man
stroke and your whole hips would just
your body would leave the floor and he
twists in midair
and as soon as your feet touch the
ground you shuffle around again and you
decided that
from and he could just cuz I'm so scared
he could tap me and over he could just
go back where's my mum pinned me down
and beat me to death that's yeah I'm so
scared never got angry
never ever shaken oh my god
childhood is crazy ah crazy I hate you I
love that
brother there was a thing exactly what
you said the other day about like you
have to find the jest in every
everything everything in your life like
I like the fact that I can talk about
this yeah and say cuz I have if I was a
different guy hmm I could like find an
excuse to blame any kind of my behavior
how I feel or resentments unlike my
childhood and I could talk to a
therapist it sound formative I can't do
this because of this and like if I feel
like I generally feel like if you can
try your best to find the funny in any
bad situation you automatically feel
better within yourself and like there's
a situation I thought about I decided
I'm not gonna do it today
mmm one day I will do it yeah but like
the worst worst worst thing that ever
happened I've told you before
mmm I sold all of you before when we
were in Miami we had that hot top I
remember the worst worst worst worst
worst thing that ever happened to me hmm
when I was a kid and it like like it it
like what every time I used to think
about it it used to literally like I
don't know he used to like make me feel
so weird and down and like I can't
scriber usages yeah you should just [ __ ]
me up when they were used to think about
it and me and my brother do not speak
about it yeah and only found out
recently that because he was so young he
thought it was a dream he didn't know
was real and then he brought it up at
his birth we were we were at birthday
dinner mmm and he bought my mom wasn't
there on my parents one there and he we
will having drinks and stuff and he
brought it up as like a joke yeah and I
was like I was there and I was out what
the [ __ ] are you doing yeah and then he
looked at me and was like until he's at
James until you just said what the [ __ ]
you doing I thought was a [ __ ] dream
and now I was just seeing your reaction
I've just realized it wasn't and my
world is my world is spinning and I was
I'd be really were no [ __ ] a dream
that's for damn sure
and we haven't ever spoken about it even
after that we've never spoken about it
and recently I told someone I told
someone about it and she was laughing
her [ __ ] tits off and I was like the
[ __ ] you laugh in that yeah and she
was like I'm sorry like I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry like it's not funny yeah
it's not funny yeah but it's [ __ ]
funny yeah and I'm like nah this this is
this is my like deepest darkest secret
like I don't [ __ ] I've really taught a
few people in my life this like why you
laughing and she's like I don't know
that I don't know and [ __ ] like the more
she laughed I was like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
laughing like this is my heart this is
my soul like don't laugh yeah and then
she was like you're right ain't funny
it's not funny and then like she stopped
talking and this she just started
laughing again and I'm like nah mad and
I'm just like stewing students to
experience to it and then a couple days
I was thinking why did she find that so
funny and then I said it out loud to
myself I said the whole story out loud
to myself and I was like rah is actually
funny yeah if you take away all the
darkness for me though he's [ __ ]
funny and I was aware as soon as like I
acknowledged that mmm I felt like a
weight come off my chest yeah and I was
like he's all about mm he's horrible
yeah but the the resentment I feel him
inside myself going it's literally gone
yeah and like I said I'm not gonna say
on here yeah by murder I made it was a
few weeks ago I made a note in my phone
and I was like one day I'm gonna have
the balls to say it yeah on the pod yeah
and I'm gonna tell it and it will be
funny and alphabet and I just wanted to
like use it as an expression of just
like bad [ __ ] happens to everyone all
the time everyone but if you can't find
the funny in it then you're just gonna
stew forever yeah cuz I've been stewing
on that for the last what how old was I
six seven yeah so what the last 12 years
it's a long time it's a very long time
yeah so even longer than 12 years what
I'm about 20 years the last 20 years one
years I've been sitting on that for 21
years and it's been vexing me every time
I've ever 4x8 sends me mad and what you
told us what I told you eight years ago
yeah yeah but boy yeah you gotta find
the funny and [ __ ] you know it's hard
though it was hard for me to find that
it's hard obviously because you're
experienced in it you're going through
it it's part of you as part of them as
part your favorite so for you to laugh
as it's happening or when you think
about it it would never be the cases
it's when you say out to someone else or
blah blah that's when you can be like it
maybe it's not it's bad but you can see
there you can see the funny circus like
the people you tell they can empathize
with you yeah the same way we were
talking about like like women getting
raped and stuff like that yeah and all
the bad things that happen to people
that will never happen to you yeah like
when you hear stuff at that all you can
do is empathize it all you can do is
empathize you'll never be able to truly
understand or feel what they're feeling
yeah so like obviously when I'm telling
people I'm expecting them for some
reason to feel the way I feel when I'm
saying it yeah and like when I'm saying
it like I'm feeling horrible and I'm
expecting them to feel that way
and she just didn't feel that way and
it's because it's nothing to do with her
didn't happen to her yeah so it was easy
for her to like laugh and then boy yeah
once I laughter by hours like bruv it's
literally gone like every bad feeling I
had about is literally gone it's crazy
it's actually crazy like was when we say
oh you got to find everything funny I do
believe it but then now that I know I've
got a true exact example of that yeah
like a pizza monster I'm just like oh
wow that actually is the truth yeah it's
the hundred percent way is the truth but
it's hard to find something funny
obviously when something bad is
happening to you of course hard you've
just got to let go and let God man just
move on kind of thing and just for real
man try and find the jest and everything
that's that that's true happiness mum
just being free and being like you know
what she happens
keep it moving mum laughter [ __ ] happens
all the time all day every day [ __ ]
happens all the time and people
literally sometimes I do feel like
people make a choice to either hold on
to it yeah or to let it go and people
make out like it's not a choice
and sometimes it might be a hard choice
by still think it's always a choice
especially when it comes down to
forgiving people like um I got this like
big thing about forgiveness like
forgiveness when people like hold
grudges like I don't hog riders really
ever but from that one thing that I
mentioned I don't really hold grudges
ever and like obviously there's certain
people in life that always hold a grudge
always if someone have done them wrong
or if like someone's hurt them suffered
that they all wait there were resent
that person to the day they die and they
don't want to hear from that person
every time they think about that person
they get angry but it's like if you
don't forgive that person while you're
out here feeling all these resentments
you do realize they're not feeling yeah
they're very out from there move they're
moving on from they're not thinking
about this [ __ ] it's not like oh yeah
he's not like every time you feel angry
they can feel it there in China
somewhere they like are [ __ ] yeah like
not this again not caring again
yeah it's like they have no idea that
you're feeling angry yeah like your day
is ruined
and they're just chillin chillin they
don't give a [ __ ] it's not even on their
radar yeah so like someone said there's
a quote and I really can't I wish I
could remember exactly what it says but
it's like like resentment is like trying
to poison someone by taking the pill
yourself or drinking the poison yourself
and like you're trying to yeah you're
trying to kill someone by drinking the
poison yourself that makes it and
because it's only you you you're the
only one that's fit in this that
person's not finished so why why do you
bother holding a grudge because they
don't care and more time a lot of the
time whilst you're out here on these
resentments when you do actually see
that person and they can see they like
they can see you still gotta graduate by
it they're even more they give even less
of a [ __ ] their blood big man you're a
joke yeah you're a joke get over it fam
get over it and then then they just move
on even more higher my E like I'm the
bigger man and they just walked off and
you're just still there stewing firm so
yeah I you've gotta find a funny in
everything you just gotta get over [ __ ]
quickly because it will eat you up boy
that's easier said than done
are they horse but just like everything
we say on here yeah way easier said than
done
boy you got making it you have to you on
you have to try to climb you can't be
free and happy on this you just let go
just have to let go and just be for
yourself man yeah man be happy I can't
think of anything that I've apart from
that one thing I do I can't think of
anything that I've held on to and
resentment and I'm angry at people about
that it's just it's just pointless even
[ __ ] that's happened in to me like right
now like the stuff we were talking about
earlier even stuff it's happening right
now I'm still like know that person is
just a sad person so at first they're
just a sad depressed person let them be
sad if they want to be sad they can be
safe I'm like if that makes their day if
that makes if/then trying to ruin my day
makes their day their problem cool firm
that's my good deed for the day
yeahwe but my day is blessed trust me
I'm fine but yeah if I'm [ __ ] was funny
indeed want to rap yeah